Podcast.
Podcast. Podcast. Stefan Tietz und Förendin Willi-Willi-Wig. Das wird ne Menge Spaß. Ja, hallo. Du, für das Intro reicht das. Reicht absolut abgenommen, wunderbar, mehr ist gar gar nicht nötig. Danke an David für dieses fantastische Intro und neben mir schwungvoll wie immer. Stefan Tietze? Und gegenüber von mir, und jetzt Geometrie-Freaks, viel Spaß mit dem Bild in eurem Kopf, Flo Nebel. Peripher links leicht von mir, Stefan Maria Tietze, schön, dass du da bist. Wenn das war David. Florentin rechts neben Stefan ist und Karl links neben Florentin, wer ist dann rechts? In einem wieviel Dimensionsraum müssen wir uns bewegen, damit diese Aussagen wahr sein können. Stefan Tietze ist im Raum, David ist auch mit dabei. Vielen Dank für dieses Intro mit einem mysteriösen Anklang. Wir wissen nicht genau, ob es dir gut geht, bitte melde dich mal. Kurz eine Frage in eigener Sache. Kommen noch genug Intros rein? Ich habe schon tatsächlich relativ lange nicht mehr meine alten Klapp-Sparten-Laptop aufgemacht. Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, die Tatsache, dass ich so lange nicht mehr geprüft habe, unser E-Mail-Postfach, zeigt, dass wir noch genug im Back-Catalog haben.
Genau.
Die einzige Nachricht, die ich noch in den Podcast bringen kann, ist, ich habe den Namen vergessen, der Einsenderin, aber wir haben vor einigen Jahren darüber gesprochen, Beefy mit Schokomantel. Mhm, zwei Wochen, ja.
Und die junge Dame, deren Namen ich vergessen habe, wir nennen sie mal Malen. Malen hat geschrieben, dass sie immer ein Snickers
halbiert und einem Hotdog
gleich eine Beefy dazwischen
legt und sie nennt das
entweder Sneephy oder
Biffers, ich weiss nicht mehr genau eins von beiden.
Klingt beides wie Reinigungsmittel.
Ja, stimmt.
Also entweder hieß sie Malen
oder Martha und entweder hat sie
Sneephy oder Biffers genannt. Also wir haben jetzt eine Permutationstabelle von vier Möglichkeiten und nur eine davon ist richtig. Aber das Bild, was entsteht, ist ja in etwa das gleiche. Also von daher vielen Dank an, ja, zu... Ja, das war eine tolle Idee. Nee, sehr schön. Ich habe mich nur gefragt, wie viele überhaupt noch Intros reinschicken, seitdem du so hart durchgegriffen hast. Nein, nein, nein, nein, die Leute lieben das, die lieben Beschränkungen, Beschränkungen reizen ja auch die Kreativität, wenn du weisst, okay, schreib eine Geschichte mit drei Sätzen. Florentin kam wieder. Okay, guck mal, du hast jetzt zum Beispiel die zwei anderen Sätze gar nicht genutzt. Das ist jetzt aber Kreativität. Drei Wörter, habe ich gedacht. Okay. Was war noch mal die Aufgabe? Das war eins zu eins ich in der Schule. Ich spreche zu leise, ich spreche zu leise, tut mir leid. Kannst du lauter und deutlicher sprechen? Dann mal eine Geschichte mit vier Worten, nur vier Wörter. Florentin kam wieder zu sch... Hm? Ja, jetzt müsste man recht schräben. Na, zu spät kann man zusammenschreiben. Zu spät. Da werden jetzt... Und es ist so nach unten geschrieben, so ganz am Rand entlang. Naja, aber man weiss es nicht. Da muss man genau wissen, was man zusammenschreibt und was nicht. Aber willst du mich irgendwie verarschen oder was? Ist es witzig, dann da sozusagen über Florentin zu schreiben? Visieso denn? Wieso denn? Stefan, wenn du mich provozierst, ohne Witz, ich bin on edge. Ich hau dir in die Fresse, wirklich. Du haust mir in die Fresse? Stefan, wenn da noch mal so Stefan, ey, wenn da noch mal so ein Spruch kam, ich hau dir zwischen deine kleinen schwachen Augen. Ich hau dir auf deinen Schwachpunkt, ich sehe deinen Schwachpunkt. Mit zwischen meinen Augen? Ich hau dir so, ich hau dir so, ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen aggressiv in der Zeit. Warum? Weil ich habe ein Hobby, was heißt Hobby, aber anscheinend hat der Algorithmus Gott entschieden, dass ich mich jetzt für Kampfsport interessiere, aber nicht für irgendeinen Kampfsport, sondern es gibt so einen Typen auf YouTube und Instagram, der ist absolut faszinierend, weil der ist so ein Türsteher-Typ
und der macht so Ratschläge, wie man
einfach Leute zusammen prügelt.
Und der sagt immer so, ja gut, im Ring,
da kannst du hier deine Spiränzchen machen oder so,
aber in der Strasse machst du, bap, bap, bap,
da machst du rechts, links, rechts,
und dann sagst du, willst du noch einer auf die Fresse,
und dann machst du, bap, bap, bap, bap,
und der ist so, no bullshit,
der Account heisst auch irgendwie so UCC Vollgas, also einfach so direkt aufs Maul. Weisst du, was ich spannend finde an solchen Videos für den, weil du gibst ihm auch ein Herz. Also alles an seinem Aussehen ist böse und schlimm und krass, er macht am Ende ein Insta-Reel, mitnimmt, wo du ein Herzchen geben kannst, du kannst es weiter kannst es weiterleiten. Und er sagt auch, man, wir haben nicht genug Herzchen bekommen, wir müssen mehr Content machen. Und der ist immer so geil, weil in jedem Video sagt er, Ring ist nicht das gleiche wie Strasse. Und diesen Satz habe ich wirklich schon dutzende Male gehört und ich habe es langsam verstanden. Der Ring ist nicht die Strasse. Und wenn einer am Messer kommt, der hat immer so ganz schnelle Schläge in kurzer Abfolge mit beiden Händen. Was das Nokia 2.10, was das gefilmt hat, nicht wirklich einfangen kann. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Und dann wird es bei TikTok noch runterkomprimiert auf zwei P. Ja, und der ist einfach fantastisch. Und deswegen, der sagt immer so, hau dem auf die Fresse, bevor der Kampf überhaupt losgeht. Der sagt immer, wenn mir einer kommt, wenn an der Tür einer kommt und sagt, ja willst du was, sofort, sofort aufs Maul. Und seitdem denke ich mir, ja, die einzige Chance, die ich habe, einen Kampf überhaupt zu überleben, geschweige denn zu gewinnen, ist, ich prügel einfach drauf ein, bevor der Kampf überhaupt losgeht. Moment, du warst gar nicht so weit weg mit deiner Kreiseltaktik. Ey Stefan, ohne Witz. Du hattest die Kreiseltaktik, dass du dich ... Ich bin kurz davor, die so hart auf die Fresse zauern. Ich mach die Windmühle. Genau, wie hieß der nochmal? Müder? Wie hieß der nochmal der Typ? Mark Glüber irgendwie sowas aus dem Sketch, den wir gemacht haben. Ah ja. Der hatte Hübner, Mark Hübner oder irgendwie sowas. Ich weiss nicht mehr ganz genau. Ja, bei guter Arbeit, wo es den einen Menschen gab, der die Technik beim UFC revolutioniert hat. Ein Typ, den man nicht ansieht, dass er, also Florentin, dass er kämpfen kann. Okay, wirklich. Einen Punkt. Ich bin kurz davor, ich wittere einen Kampf und ich will ihn erst schlagmässig direkt gewinnen, indem ich dir direkt komplett auf beide Ohren gleichzeitig schlage. Weißt du, der meint so, ja da kam einer an irgendwie und dann habe ich dem erstmal direkt das Gelee aus den Augen gedrückt. Ich denke mir, bitte was, da kommt jemand zu dir an die Tür und du drückst ihm die Augen aus oder was? Der ist einfach so no bullshit.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich nicht in den Club gehe. Und der muss auch so hart strafbar sein.
Wenn du da an die Tür kommst und dann bitte direkt der Augensaft aus den Augen gepresst.
Leute, der hat da auch so einen Stockkampf.
Der hat so einen kleinen Stock dabei.
Nunschucks.
Der ist einfach nur so einen kleinen Stock.
Und er sagt, ja, also wenn ich mich entscheiden könnte, Messer oder Stock, ich würde immer den Stock nehmen, warum du dich auskennst, weil da kannst du dich nicht selber mitverletzen und alles und so. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks.
Nantschucks.
Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. Nantschucks. modischen Entscheidungen hinterfrage. Seit letzter Woche sind wir ja eh modisch im
Fall. Ja, ich habe mir ja wieder mein Soft Summer Blue eingezogen, ein Blau.
Und man merkt das sofort, deine traurigen hinterfrage, seit letzter Woche sind wir ja ehemodisch im Gefluss. Ja, ich habe mir ja wieder mein Soft Summer Blue
eingezogen, ein Blau.
Und man merkt, dass sofort deine traurigen
Augen sofort rausspringen, einem ins Gesicht
quasi. Ja. Das ist richtig schön.
Und bei dem, die Jogginghose
ist auch ein bisschen unvorteilhaft, aber der ballert
alles zusammen. Und seitdem bin ich wirklich so
Moment, Frontin Will sagt, bei ihm
war die Jogginghose
ein bisschen unvorteilhaft.
Ähm ... Moment, Frontyn Will sagt, bei ihm war die Jogginghose ein bisschen unvorteilhaft. Einen Satz, den ich verstehe, in diesem Kontext? Schwierig. Naja, aber weißt du, Ring ist halt nicht das gleiche wie Strasse. Und wo fungst du die Jogginghose? Definitiv nicht im Ring. Weil Ring und Strasse ist unterschiedlich. Das haben wir verstanden. Im Ring kannst du da machen, deinen Capoeira oder so. Aber auf der Strasse blablabla. Musst du sofort ran, musst du sofort auf die Augen schlagen. Du musst sofort direkt in die Nasenlöcher reinschlagen. Jetzt war ja auch in der ganzen Politikwelt und Bundestagsblablabla war ja immer TikTok auch so ein Thema. Ah, die Jugend radikalisiert sich, alle hängen zu viel vor TikTok, blablabla. Und dann Wahlerfolg der Linken, ah, das muss an TikTok gelegen haben und so weiter und so fort. Und irgendwie insgeheim muss ich immer so ein bisschen grinsen, weil das, was bei mir hängen bleibt bei TikTok ist, schwarze Bären sind gefährlicher als braune Bären oder Ring ist nicht gleich Strasse. Genau. Also das sind so Dinge wie, in Amerika ist es anscheinend eine Sportart für alte Midlife-Crisis-Männer auf Rollschuhen, so eine Rollschuldisco, so einen Rollschuh-Tanz aufzuführen. Die fahren im Kreis, es ist super niedlich, und dann fahren die Zufall aus. Und die walzen alles weg. Also da sind Kinder auf der Bahn, ist denen scheissegal, die haben keine Zeit, was zu bereichen. Ich muss sagen, eine lockere, sexy Hüfte, und dann wird da der Fuss rausgeschmissen, und im Hintergrund fährt da noch irgendwie ein jünger Typ mit, wo man denkt, wie bist du denn reingekommen? Lauf, lauf, lauf, nimm die Rollschuhe und ras weg. Ja, aber man muss es ja auch weitertragen, das Hobby. So was wird mir die ganze Zeit angezeigt und ich werde vielleicht radikalisiert, kann schon sein. Vielleicht hat das deine Wahlentscheidung beeinflusst, du weisst nur nicht genau wie. Das ist ja alles so, ich glaube, der Algorithmus ist auch nicht so direkt so, zeigt dir Wahlwerbung, sondern der manipuliert dich so subversiv, dass du es gar nicht merkst. Es gibt ja auch so dieses Benutzerprofil, auf Instagram kannst du dir anschauen, als was du von dem Werbealgorithmus, also was deine Interessen sind, die analysiert wurden. Und da ist teilweise irgendwie Fundamentalist Christian. Und ich denke mir so, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, aber anscheinend hat der das irgendwie so mit reingebracht. Bei mir ist halt viel Strassenkampf. Angry Issues. Die Strasse ist halt nicht das gleiche wie im Ring. Wenn du mit deinen Ringtechniken auf der Strasse ankommst, du kommst nicht weit. Sondern du musst einfach direkt, wenn die dir blöd kommt, musst du direkt die Augen ausdrücken, du musst ihm die Ohren abreissen, sofort. Keine Gnade, musst du sofort hin. Aber das ist auch so ein Ding, es heisst ja Martial Arts.
Also das ist ja eine Kunst, Kampfkunst sagt man ja auch, wo ich mir denke, was genau ist die Kunst dabei, weil du drückst ihm das Augengeleet raus, du spaltest den Schädel, du tötest ihn und seine Nachkommen in schneller Schlagabfolge, Du musst einfach einmal linkes Auge, rechtses Auge, linke Auge und dann dem Kind vor der Fond auch nochmal Schlag in die Kehle und dann ist alles ausgeschaltet und niemand kann den rächen und dann bist du direkt bam bam bam bam, bist du direkt wieder an der Tür. Weil Tür ist nicht das gleiche wie Ring. Definitiv nicht. Nee genau, und wo kein Kläger, da kein Richter. Wo ein Schläger, da kein Kläger. Ja. Ist mein Motto.
So heisst mein Dojo.
Wenn du alle ausschaltest, gibt es keine Zeugen. Wenn die Zeugen keine Augen mehr haben, wird der Richter nicht aussagen, weil der Richter sagt, sie haben keine Augen, sie können nicht dann nicht sehen haben. Kein Problem. Und so musst du ganz schnell sein. Das heisst, auch ich im Zug, ich war jetzt mal seit langer Zeit wieder im Zug, bin auch, ja, Ruheabteil hier so, Entschuldigung, können Sie leise sein, hätte er sich nur einmal kurz umgedreht, ich hätte ihn sofort, bapap, sofort bearbeitet, sofort die Augen rausgedrückt, ich war on edge, ich bin seitdem wirklich on edge. Hat die mal geredet? Hat geredet, ja.
Ja, ich war tatsächlich Zug und ich dachte mir,
diese Erstschlagsidee
finde ich plausibel.
Wenn du was machst, machst sofort.
Und ich bin in den Waggon reingekommen.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit bei Nukes.
Ich bin für Atomwaffen.
Nee, ich denke die ganze Zeit an Nukes.
Okay, andere Aussage. Nicht als bejahendes Statement zu nehmen. Ich meine nur, ich denke die ganze Zeit... Ich bin auch für Atomwaffen. Nee, aber wenn du sagst, Erstschlag, der ist ja nicht der wichtige, habe ich jetzt gelernt. Ich habe gelernt, dass die Zweitschlagskapazität die wichtige ist, nämlich die Mutual Destruction. Ja, der Spiegel quasi. Spiegel ist quasi auf geophilischer Ebene. Ja, deswegen die Atomwaffen, die du hast als kleines Land, musst du die ganze Zeit bewegen, damit, wenn das Land getroffen wird, du trotzdem zurückschlagen kannst. Nur wenn du das glaubhaft vermitteln kannst, und da geht es auch nicht darum, dass es passiert, sondern dass du glaubhaft vermitteln kannst, dass das passiert, dann bist du eine ernstzunehmende Macht.
Du bist keine ernstzunehmende Macht.
Nee, deswegen brauche ich den Erstschlag.
Aber du wirst umgeknockt im Zweitschlag.
Du brauchst Zweitschlagkapazität.
Ja, aber wenn du ihm wirklich die Augen ausdrückst, alle Finger brichst, Beine brichst,
dann ist mit Zweitschlag nichts mehr.
Der hat kein Atom-U-Boot irgendwo im Main. Ja, aber das ist so, als ob Italien Serbien angreift. Endlich? Also ich finde, die haben sich schon lange genug versteckt, den Schwanz eingezogen, ehrlich gesagt. Nee, das ist so, als ob Italien greift Russland an mit einem Bömmchen. La Bomba. Und dann sagt Russland, Bombini greift an, Russland sagt, ja das war's, tschüss, ciao. Ciao. Ja. Und zerbombt Rom.
Du kannst auch niemanden angreifen, wenn du den Zweitschlag nicht überstehst. Das stimmt, deswegen... Ich komme jetzt aus der Ministerstechnik. Das ist richtig. Vielleicht hast du recht, vielleicht muss ich es nochmal überdenken. Ich war aber bereit, zu prügeln, sofort loszuprügeln, weil ich kam schon mal in diesen Waggon rein und habe gesehen, okay, hier gibt es genug Arbeit für mich. Erstmal die Sonnenschaubehaube ist unten runtergezogen, die eh eine soziale Katastrophe ist, weil wenn du am Fenster sitzt, kannst du die Sonnen, wie nennt man das, Sonnenschutz, Sonnenhaube? Ich weiss es, aber ich will die Hälfte nicht. Du lässt mich mal wieder zappeln. Dir gefällt, wie ich zappel, ne? Ich zappel auch gern für dich. Rollo. Ja, so eine Jalousie, so eine Sonnenjalousie, so Die Sonnenblende, ich finde die Sonnenblende gar nicht falsch. Die Sonnenblende, so, weil du ziehst die für dich runter, aber auch für den Hintermann oder Vornemann. So, aber da halte ich für die 50-50-Regel, wenn du mehr als 50% Anteil am Fenster hast, ist es deine Sonnenblende. Ja, aber die Leute fragen in der Regel nicht, es gibt keine Kommunikation, es ist einfach ein Krieg. Es ist wirklich du hast es gut ausgedrückt, Italien, Russland, so ein Kräftemessens, so ein Kräfteszen. Und da habe ich genau genailt. Du hast es geopolitisch wirklich auf den Punkt gebracht. Das beschreibt den Konflikt zwischen Italien und Russland, finde ich mir am besten. Richtig. Die Sonnenblenden zu. Genau, beide sind geblendet, aber einer will trotzdem rausschauen, weil endlich mal Sommer ist, ja, endlich Queen of Summer, S of Summer und dann raus und ich habe schon gesehen, okay, da reden Leute, da ist die Sonnenjalousie runtergezogen und ich will eigentlich gerne aus dem Fenster schauen. Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich wirklich die bewusste Entscheidung getroffen, mach's sofort. Weil ansonsten sitzt du da eine halbe Stunde und denkst, okay, wenn ich es jetzt anspreche, ist es auch blöd.
Sofort, und ich habe sofort, wirklich noch bevor ich mich hingesetzt habe, ich habe meinen Rucksack auf meinen Platz getan, bin zu den Leuten gesagt, habe gesagt, Entschuldigung, das ist der Ruhebereich, könnten Sie bitte leise sein, habe mich hingesetzt, habe die Sonnenschutz hochgezogen, war der fucking badass, es war komplett still, hole aus meinem Rucksack meine Wasserflasche, mache sie auf, Mineralwasser sprudelt raus und spritzt mir ins Gesicht. Das meine ich nämlich. Das war genau in dem Moment. Das meine ich. Zweitschlagskapazität. Du kannst nicht auftreten wie der grosse Zampano. Genau. Wenn die Mineralwasserbombe geht. Signor Zampano, Zampano. Du kannst nicht auftreten, wenn du danach Schwäche zeigst.
Du kannst nicht eine Kriegspartei sein plötzlich und sagen, sie sind leise, bitte stellen sie ihr Kind ruhig, sie können den Döner nicht im Zug essen, sie ziehen die Schuhe wieder an und runter mit dem Fuss vom Sitz Sonnenblende hoch und nimmst dann dein Wasser raus, was durch die ganzen Zähne springt.
Das geht nicht.
Dann musst du bitte, und deswegen traue ich mich auch nicht, j durch die ganzen C springt. Das geht nicht. Dann musst du bitte,
und deswegen traue ich mich auch nicht, jemals sowas zu machen. Auch nur eines davon. Die Fallhöhe ist zu hoch. Du bist oben auf dem Zehn-Meter-Turm und du kannst jetzt nur noch fallen. Du kannst nicht wochenlang auf dem Zehn-Meter-Turm stehen. Da ist nicht genug Platz. Die Chance, dass dann meine Airpods nicht mit meinem Handy connected sind und ich schaue wegen Film irgendwie auf Schauspieler-Lautstärk.
Oder Lautstärk.
Genau. Das ist halt einfach ein Problem. dass dann meine Airpods nicht mit meinem Handy connected sind und ich schaue irgendeinen Film irgendwie auf Schlepp-Lautstärk.
Genau, das ist halt einfach ein Problem.
Und das kann halt passieren.
Aber das ist das Problem an Mineralwasser.
Ich habe jetzt Mineralwasser für mich entdeckt, ich habe viel Genuss,
aber es ist einfach die
demütigendste Geste, die es überhaupt gibt.
Also,
deine Autorität ist wirklich am Boden.
Du kannst nicht sagen, Schatz,
ich glaube, wir sollten mal überlegen, ob wir getrennt nicht glücklicher wären. Oh, fuck, shit. Und es ist einfach komplett demütig. Ja, es ist demütig natürlich mit Farbstoff wie Cola. Ich denke an Cola, ich denke an Mr. Pepper. Ich denke an Mr. Pepper vor seinem Doktor. Der Doktortitel aberkannt wurde. Genau, wie wir wissen, weil er gefällt. Dr. Pepper hat nämlich Sachen reingeschrieben, die er abgeschrieben hat von von Pepsi. Die es, Dr. Pepsi. Dr. Pepsi. Pepsi MD. Weil ich musste zum Zugrennen, ich hätte es eigentlich antizipieren können, aber ich bin noch nicht so tief drin im Mineralwasser-Game, deswegen diese tickende Zeitbombe hat einfach nicht funktioniert. Du bist gerannt zum Zug? Ich bin gerannt zum Zug, ja. Ich finde nichts demütigerendes, als wenn du als erwachsener Mensch bezwungen bist zu rennen. Ich bin vor allem ein richtig erbärmlicher Renner. Ein guter Renner. Ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar. Du wirst ein guter Renner, weil deine Hüfte auf einer Ebene Ebene ist. Aber niemand kann gut rennen mit einem schweren Rucksack. Ich fordere, okay, Usain, falls du zuhörst, Usain Bolt, ich fordere dich heraus. Es gibt keinen anderen Usain. 100 Meter, okay, dann bleiben wir bei Usain. Aber danke, dass du Usain, dass du beim Rennen, das ging um Rennen, und du hast bei Usain noch gemeint, du müsstest das Publikum educaten mit dem Nachnamen. Ja, wer weiss, Leute, die sich vielleicht gutkennen kennen, ja gut, welcher Usain jetzt, wovon redet er? So, Usain, ich freue dich heraus. Ich, Fetty McFett gegen dich, schnellster Mann der Welt, aber du hast einen Rucksack an, du hast einen Eastpack mit zwei, einer Flasche Mate, die später auch noch hochgegangen ist, wie du dir vorstellen kannst, mit einer Flasche Mate, mit einer Flasche Mineralwasser. Haben die Leute schon angefangen, wieder zu reden, nach der Wasserasche oder nach der Mate erst? Genau, dann hat er erst der Zauber gebrochen, so, ah, das ist ein Vollidiot. Ah, das ist ein Vollidiot, aber wir können machen, was wir wollen. Ja, so sind beide einfach, ja, Menschen. Man kennt sie ja, richtig. Ich wollte in den Haus, weil ich glaube, mit Rucksack bist du nicht so schnell. Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht. Man hat sich ja überlegt, man hat Rennen gehabt, als Wettrennen, als Disziplin, Olympisch, bla bla bla bla. Und dann hat man sich überlegt, wie kriegen wir das Ganze noch ein bisschen spannender, ah, wir laufen länger. Ah, dann noch ein bisschen länger, ah, okay, wir gehen, gehen schnell, hat noch jemand Ideen? Genau, und dann kam irgendwann Hürdenlauf, also wir machen es noch schwieriger. Hindernislauf. Ich wäre jetzt dafür, neue Olympische Disziplin mit Anorak, Jeans, so eine unhandliche Jeans, Mütze, so eine Bommelmütze, die hin und her bommelt, so eine schwere Daunenjacke und dann so einen Rucksack. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich finde generell, jede Sportart sollte nur zehn Sekunden lang dauern. Aber man erhöht halt den Schwierigkeitsgrad. Also es wird halt immer schwerer, aber du sagst nicht, okay, wir machen zehn Sekundenrennen, wir machen zwanzig Sekundenrennen, wir machen Marathon, die alle machen nur zehn Sekunden, aber die krassen Sportler müssen dann halt noch ein Fahrrad tragen oder so oder irgendwie sowas, dass sie einfach noch dabei sind, dass es noch schwerer wird, damit wir ein bisschen Zeit sparen. Was mir gerade auffällt. Ich will ständig Sport gucken, jetzt Bundesliga geht wieder los, ich schaue das Sport und ich denke mir, Leute, was machen die FC Paderborn, wo seid ihr, warum kriegt ihr nicht mal irgendwie euren Kopf aus der Sandwüste, aus den Dünen, Entschuldigung, warum kriegt ihr endlich nicht mal euren Kopf aus den Dünen? Ich meine, die hat Lagen, ich meine, sorry, das ist erste FC Bundesliga, können die nicht ihre Rucksäcke vom Platz nehmen, oder? Bin ich der Einzige? Ich bin jetzt der Einzige, die hatten, das sind Profisportler, da liegen noch die ganzen fucking Rucksäcke auf dem Platz, der eine schiesst ins Tor und der Ball rollt nicht ins Tor, weil Rucksäcke rumliegen, können die nicht vor dem Spiel ihre Rucksäcke wegtragen, gibt es da nicht Leute in so einem vollbesetzten Stadionion? Oder bin ich jetzt ein, Sie, der sich drüber aufregen? Da hat es gar keine Wellen geschlagen, da lagen die Ersatzschuhe rum, da lagen die Rucksäcke, die Anoraks lagen am Spielfeldrand rum und dann räumt das Zeug noch weg. Das ist der Relatable-Humor für den Leuten. Ja, das ist Fußball-Content. Mich nervt es einfach. Ich verstehe das. Ich habe gerade nur gedacht, es gibt es die anderen Leichtathletik-Sportarten, die alle so ein bisschen egaler sind als das 100-Meter-Rennen. Nur weil es albern wäre, die Anreise, die Snacks besorgen, das Platz suchen, sich hinsetzen, Vorprogramm, Leute rennen für 9,1 Sekunde, man steht auf und geht zum Parkplatz zurück, steht im Parkplatz im Stau, fährt raus, Schranke geht nicht auf. Ach, Kacke, ah fuck, hast du das Parkticket nicht bezahlt? Das wäre automatisch. Wir sollten doch ein, hast du es nicht gezogen, als du reingefahren bist? Du hast es gemacht. Nee, du bist doch auf der Fahrerseite. Ja, okay, gut, dann, dann, ja, dann, ich muss hinten winken, damit die es reinlassen. Alle müssen es zurücksetzen, alle müssen es zurücksetzen. So, und das ist ja albern, und deswegen gibt es andere Sportarten auch noch, wie zum Beispiel Diskus. Ja. Tellerwerfen. Tellerwerfen. Sperrwerfen ergibt noch Sinn für mich, aber dann gibt es auch noch Diskus und diese ganzen Schwachsinn-Sportarten. Sorry, ich will niemandem zu nachgeben, aber es ist albern. Aber Diskenwerfen ist natürlich auch militärischer kompletter Unsinn. Ich weiss nicht, ob mal eine griechische Armee gesagt hat, lass uns Disken werfen und die wurde komplett vernichtet einfach, komplett ausgelöscht. Wäh, aber während du irgendwie in Türstehern beim Menschen umbringen, zurichten zuguckst, habe ich jetzt einen professionellen, wir nähern uns dem anderen an, Kampfbau war ja immer mein Thema. Ich habe einen professionellen Bogenschützen gesehen und sein Skill war sehr beeindruckend, weil ich dachte immer, dass so, wenn man so Mittelalterfilme sieht und die schiessen sich ab, dass immer so eine überhöhte Idee war, von dem, wie es eigentlich war. Alle schiessen in den Himmel und hoffen, dass sich jemanden erwischen. Das ist meine Vorstellung von Burtis. Wahrscheinlich ist auch ein bisschen Wahrheit hinter, aber die können schon sehr genau treffen und vor allem auch geil ausweichen. Und dann rennen die so und das ist wirklich wie Legolas. Also das fand ich sehr beeindruckend. Das war so wie Paintball mit so Hindernissen, nur halt mit allartem Bogen in der Hand. So war das, ja. Das war früher im Mittelalter so, die sind alle rumgewetzt, haben... Also der klassische mittelalterliche Schießkunst ist ja, du machst einen Schuss, dann machst du einen Rückwärtssaldo und dann machst du wieder einen Schuss. Also so ist es ja in den Traktaten von 12.68 von Luigi Maggioni festgelegt worden, der damals in Italien, also reiner Zufall jetzt nicht verwandt oder verschwägert, den Kaiser umgebracht hat und dann Rückwärtssaldo gemacht hat. Ja, ja, er sah so gut aus. Ja, um den Hunden zu zeigen, das können die nicht machen. Und die beglauben, er war B-6-Saldo. Wissen wir nicht. Gut, aber ist ja auch ... Du weisst, die Leute damals schon ... Also, die fanden das cool. Ja. Die fanden ihn cool. Ja. Ja, ich habe auch Bogenschießen gerne praktiziert. Und dann war so der Punkt im Freundeskreis, wir alle Herr-der-Ringe-Fans haben alle alle Bögen gebaut, rumgeschossen, irgendwie klar. Und dann sind ein paar in den Bogenverein gegangen, wie Sportschützen, Bogenschützeverein. Und das war für mich ein riesiger Kulturschock, weil ich war natürlich eher der Legolas-Elben-Bogenschützer im Wald und diese Sportschützen sind natürlich mit Visier und Flaschenzug und Auslöser und so. Unsch unschein ist, das Kind, was in einer Fantasy-Legolas-Phase ist, gibt es doch nichts Entzaubernderes als diese Sportbögen, die du bei Decathlon kaufst, wo dann irgendwie so 90 verschiedene Messdinger und Gegengewicht und alles super krass. Und ich dachte mir so, hä Leute, wollen wir nicht das normale klassische Bogen schützen?
Und dann meinten die nur so, du meinst intuitives Bogenschießen?
und irgendjemand hat es geschafft,
marketingmässig, das klassische Bogenschiessen als intuitiv, was wirklich so ein Esoterik-Vibe hat, so du musst eins werden
mit dem Ziel, gegenüberzustellen im technisch hochwertigen,
modernen Bogenschiießen mit Visier und ich wollte es nicht machen. Das war wahrscheinlich so was Supershooting heisst oder so was Cooles. Ja, Supershooting. Mow them all down, mow the Orcs down, so heisst das. Catch them all. Und du willst nicht sagen, ich bin ein intuitiver Bogenschützer, also ich schiesse nach Gefühl, also ich muss mich halt auch so fühlen und wollte ich mir auch nicht die Blöße geben, dann zu sagen, ich gehe jetzt alleine zum intuitiven Bogenschießen.
Ja, ich weiss auch nicht, wie es dir ging, aber alle Leute, die in der Schulzeit in Schiessvereinen sind, im weitesten Sinne Schusssport, wie das heißt, Schiessport, also, ja, schiessen. Also alle Leute, die in diesen Vereinen waren,
ich habe ein schwieriges Verhältnis zu denen gehabt.
Ja.
Du hast dann deine Übungen in der Schule,
was du machst in besonderen Situationen.
Und alle gucken immer die Leute an,
die in Schiessvereinen sind.
Weil es sind immer die in Schiessvereinen sind. Ja, ich weiss noch, zum Thema Amoklauf kam dann der Film raus, We Need to Talk About Kevin, über die Eltern von einem Amokläufer, der aber witzigerweise mit einem Bogen, Pfeil und Bogen in die Schule gegangen ist. Und so ist er ein Amor glaubt. Aber intuitiv oder Sport schützen? Nee, zum Glück nicht. Und da weiss ich noch, als der Film rauskam, gab es in meinem Freundeskreis wirklich so
ein, ach ja, jetzt komm, gab es in meinem Freundeskreis
wirklich so ein, ach ja, jetzt komm, jetzt gibt es
wieder die Diskussionen. Jetzt gibt es wieder die,
ah, Konstantinopel wurde mit
Bögen erobert, ist das nicht vielleicht doch eher
Waffe als Sportgerät? Und die
hatten wirklich Angst um ihren
Leidenssport und
dass ihnen die Bögen weggenommen
werden, dass sie entwaffnet werden
quasi, dass die UN reinkommt und irgendwie da mal aufräumt, wegen der Propaganda im Film. Also, Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr lang. Schuss, Schuss, sehr einfach nacheinander zu tätigen. In der Zeit kann jemanden umtacklen. Richtig, ja. Aber ich meine, Stefan, du bist ja ein extrem talentierter Autor.
Da ist sehr viel Anführungszeichen in dem Wort.
Naja, wenn du einen Film schreibst, überlegst du dann nicht auch, was hat das für gesellschaftliche Folgen?
Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, okay, ich mache einen Serienmörder, geht um Serienmörder, und dann musst du ja gucken, wo kommt der her, wo wurde der geboren, welches T-Shirt trägt der, das ist ja alles Negativ-Assoziationen, wie tötet der? Du hast recht, du hast vollkommen recht. Tötet der jetzt mit irgendwas, was gesellschaftlich umstritten ist, also tötet der jetzt mit einem Bogen oder so, wo du sagst, okay, da gibt es eine ges, das ist ein Sportgerät, Säure, der hat so eine, diese Biff oder wie die so ein, nee, die es so gibt, diesen Glasreiniger oder so. Sillit Bang. Sillit Boom, also so heißt der Film. Sillit Bang heißt der Film. So, aber da hättest du zum Beispiel markenrechtlich Probleme mit Sillit Bang. Und dann macht er Säure rein, die Blausäure. Er macht die oben zu und dann kann er dann so spritzen. Okay, aber er muss recht nah an seinem Gegner sein. Super nah. Und er hat auch so einen Haushaltskittel an und so ein Spültuch noch in der Hand. Und er spritzt Säure auf die Leute und dann gehen die einfach ein? Ja. Wie wollen wir das drehen? Vfx. Viel Vfx auch. Wie Vfx, also zum Beispiel sind die aus Wachs, wir bauen die in Wachs nach und dann schmelzen wir die ein. Madame Tussauds oder was? Wir könnten doch Wachsfiguren von Madame Tussauds nehmen. Ja, super. Ich meine, die rotieren ja auch. Alle Johnny Depp, also Johnny Depp und alle, die sie aussortiert haben. Dann sparen wir uns die Gage für Johnny Depp, wenn wir statt ihm einfach eine Wachsfigur, ich meine...
Alle von Madame Tussauds aussortierten Wachsfiguren können wir nehmen.
Genau, die müssen wir auch aussortiert.
Das heisst, wir haben Cameos von Kevin Spacey, Michael Jackson, Amber Heard, Johnny Depp,
ist eine Top-Besetzung für sie, Herr Hammer, Starstruck Ensemble,
aus Wachs, genau,
problematic Starstruck Ensemble, ja,ax, genau. Problematic Starstruck Ensemble. Von the sick mind of Harvey Weinstein war Waxfigur. Auch Beladen haben wir auch nochmal bekommen. Wo meine Frage war, warum gab es überhaupt jemanden als Waxfigur? Weil die Berühmte ja erst nach 9-11 zustamera. Das musst du Madame Toussaint selber fragen. Hier ist sie.
Yes, my dear? Ja, mein Lieber? What do you want to know? I am very old. I sometimes I wake up and I don't know if I'm a wax figure myself. So, I look into the mirror and I see my pale skin and wonder. Will I melt today, am I a wax figurine or not? And then I pinch myself in the arse and ich bin am Ende doch menschlich. Ein weiterer Teil mehr, Gott ist greener Erde, möge letzte sein. So what do you want to know? Also was willst du? Mr. So? Yes, my dear child. Ja, mein kleines Lieblingskind. Ich würde gerne wissen, ob ich für meinen Film, meinen Kurzfilm, Silly Bang, auch einen anderen Schauspieler, den es vielleicht noch gibt, zum Beispiel Daniel Brühl, bekommen kann. Oh, Daniel, my sweet, sweet child, Daniel. What night we had in Paris for the movie premiere from Goodbye Lenin. But he's getting old and weak, he starts to melt already under my warm hugs, sometimes at night. So it means that you are having sex with the wax figures yourself?
Sometimes at night, I'm so lonely.
And I break into... Ich breche ins Museum. Haben Sie keinen Schlüssel? Look, no, no, no, no, no, it was taken away from me. Many, many years ago, I sold it all.
But I dig a hole, and it's still there.
I don't know where the hole is.
And I know where it is, and I get into it whenever I want to.
And then sweet Daniel and myself making making sweet, sweet love all of all. He's starting to melt already, I can hardly recognize him. He is from the middle school. You can have Daniel, you can have Daniel. Be nice to him. Be nice to him. Thanks. You want to use acid on him, right? Yeah, have you in the Film? I've seen your first movie, yes. Silly Bang 1? Yes, I've seen it. Der hieß schon Silly Bang 1, weil ich war optimistisch. It was quite good, it was quite good. Ich war optimistisch. Er hieß Silly Bang 1, weil ich dachte, vermutlich ist es ein Mehrteiler besser. Look in the dumpster, that's where all of the people are who got abandoned. Spiellos, ja, direkt Unfall in der Formation Lab. Peinlich, peinlich, aber gut, passiert.
Genau, du bist drin, sehr schön, gefällt mir gut. Und ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, aber die drehen ja zwischendurch immer mal wieder diesen Formel-1-Film. Mit Brad Pitt. Da kam jetzt, glaube ich, der Fehler raus und die drehen diesen Film mit Brad Pitt. Und ich finde, das ist ein tolles Beispiel dafür, wie awkward Filme sind. Weil ich erinnere mich auch an manche Tage, wo wir gedreht haben, du warst ja auch Teil der Serie und ich weiß nicht, ob du mal so Komparsentage hattest und das ist immer so unangenehm, dass Filme machen an sich, man stellt sich immer so toll vor und ah fucking hell Hollywood und Brad Pitt, coolster, charismatischer Typ. Action und Explosion. Ehrlich gesagt, das ist der unangenehmste, das Endprodukt vielleicht ist cool, aber der Prozess ist so unangenehm und peinlich, weil die drehen nämlich diesen Film, und das finde ich wiederum ganz clever, oft dann im vollen Formel-1-Stadion, also die drehen dann an der Strecke, irgendwie das Publikum, nehmen sie es mit, damit man das alles nicht irgendwie nachstellen muss oder selber aufbauen muss, sondern die drehen dann und reisen dann so mit. Das heisst, du hast die richtigen Formel-1-Fahrer und du hast Brad Pitt und die Kameracrew und Kostüm und Maske, die halt so ein bisschen so peinlich sich da so reinzecken und dann immer wieder Szenen drehen. Und ab und zu kriegt man dann mit, ich weiß nicht, ob es bei dir auch so ist, wobei ich kriege online dann so mit, wenn die mal wieder was gedreht haben. Genau. Und es sieht immer peinlich aus. Weil, da musst du dir vorstellen, die hätten dann Qualifying, du hast Tickets bezahlt, bist bei der Strecke, die fallen dann mit 300 kmh vorbei, crazy, krass, Glendon Norris Pole Position, crazy.
Dann, wenn das vorbei ist, sagen die bitte, bleibt noch kurz sitzen, glaube ich, bringen dann so ein Formel-1-Auto, was aber nur so die Hälfte ist und auch nicht so aussieht rein, dann kommt Brad Pitt mit seinem Helm an und keine Sponsoren, also ausgedachte Sponsoren, setzt sich dann so rein und machen die eine Kamera an, sagen Action und ach nee, dann wird er noch abgeschminkt kurz und dann ah jetzt, okay, dann jetzt Action. Und dann kommen Leute an und wackeln am Auto. Dann kommen da Leute und wackeln am fucking Auto und rütteln daran und rütteln daran. Der Job, es für den ganzen Tag ist, am Auto zu rütteln. Aber ich denke mir so, wie Brad Pitt ist doch in der ganzen Kette. Vorher sind Leute, 18-Jährige mit 300, 400, 500 Sachen, na, weiß ich nicht, wie schnell die fahren, 300. Sagen wir, fahren hier rum. Und dann kommt Brad Pitt und an ihm wird gerüttelt. Brad Pitt, an ihm wird gerüttelt, an Schauspieler wird gerüttelt. Das muss man sich immer vorgewissern. Richtig. Man überhöht die, man macht die krass. Nein, das sind Menschen, an ihm wird gerüttelt. Es geht immer direkt links neben dem Bildende steht jemand, der rüttelt. Genau. Und der rüttelt auch schon seit 20 Takes. Oder der mit der Traschenrumpel immer wieder vorbeigeht, damit es so aussieht, als ob der irgendwie an Lichtern vorbeifährt. Vor allem im Film sieht Brad Pitt aus wie der coolste Typ, den es gibt, aber die Dreharbeiten sind extrem erbärmlich einfach. Und dann wurde eine andere Szene gedreht, wo er sich dann so freut über einen Sieg. Und es ist halt so unangenehm, weil dann gibt es noch jemanden mit einem Megafon, wahrscheinlich so einen Regieassistent, die dann so ruft, ja jetzt freut euch mal und dann ruft das Publikum in der Tribüne, alles, einfach Leute, die das Rennen gucken wollten, jubeln dann so, weil unten steht Brad Pitt, der die Arme so hoch macht. Und ich denke mir, dann wiederum macht es ihn doch cool, weil wie arschcool musst du sein, um nicht im Boden zu versinken. Stell dir vor, das ist die eigentliche Kunst des Schauspielers. Es fahren da crazy Leute rum, Hochleistungssportler, die ihr Leben riskieren und dann kommst du und dir wurde gerade noch gerüttelt und dann stellst du dich da hin in einem Outfit, was so ein bisschen so aussieht, aber eigentlich eine Verkleidung ist und dann freust du dich authentisch und das Publikum, du guckst in leere Gesichter, die so tun, als würden sie jubeln. Ich finde das so unangenehm. Das ist so unangenehm. Und diese ganze, dass sie das dann so parallel daran gedreht haben, mag produktionstechnisch eine gute Idee gewesen sein. Aber als Fan, als Formel-1-Fan, kriegst du jetzt die ganze Zeit Videos, wie dann ... Immer so Schlagzeilen, ja, Brad Pitt wins Mexican Grand Prix und so. Ist immer lustig, macht auch Spaß. Aber das ist nur mal das Ding, der ist Multimillionär, ist einer der krassesten Typen ever, aber manchmal darf man sich halt auch über ihn lustig machen, weil sein Job ist am Ende halt so tun als ob. Ja, Theater-Kid. Er ist halt einfach auch, der tut nur so. Ja, am Ende gewinnt dann wieder, ist dann doch wieder Jocks gegen Theater-Kids, es ist dann wieder High School All Over again, weil am Ende ist halt Lennon Norris mit seinem Smug-Lächeln halt doch noch der coolere Typ als der Schauschi, der Schauspieler Brad Pitt. Aber dann gab es eine Szene, wie er dann so aus seinem Auto aussteigt und dann fällt er um. Und im Film ist das wahrscheinlich cool. So wie du nach einem Auftritt einfach völlig übermüdet erst mal hinlegen. Aber er fällt so um, er wankt und dann fällt er um.
Und im Film wird das bestimmt
toll gemacht und toll unterlegt
und so. Wenn du aber
auf dem Rang sitzt und dann haben
das Leute gefilmt, wie die das Film
immer wieder wie Brad Pitt aus dem Auto steigt
und dann umfällt und alle
Teams sind sauer, weil die die Strecke nicht benutzen können,
weil dann da das Filmteam steht
und die Filme, diese Szene und jemand im Publikum,
du hörst wirklich so, jemand sagt so,
this movie is going to be shit.
Vielen Dank. Teams sind sauer, weil die die Strecke nicht benutzen können, weil dann da das Filmteam steht und die Filme, diese Szene und jemand im Publikum, du hörst wirklich so, jemand sagt so, this movie is going to be shit, weil es sieht auch einfach so aus. Fight, please, fight. Ja, der Publikum muss so, haben das leider drauf, Karli, wir müssen nochmal neu machen. Pss, können wir kurz. Und dann, das ist so, ich finde das so lustig, wie man dann so mitbekommt, wie unangenehm das Film machen auch sein kann. Ja, Prom und Formel 1 ist eine ganz unangenehme Situation, weil da sind dann immer Promis auch dabei und dann ist immer so, du bist ein Promi und cool und dann darf ja immer auch ein Promi, darf die schwarz-weiße Flagge wehen am Ende des Rennens. Und dann wird der auch immer eingeblendet und es gibt dann den Kommentar bei Sky mit Ralf Schumacher und die sind so halt recht bodenständig, was sowas angeht. Ich glaube, die sind jetzt nicht so richtig im Celeb-Ding drin und meistens ist dann dann Tom Holland, der die Flagge wählt und dann Ralf Schumacher so, ja, weiss ich auch nicht genau, wie das ist. Und unten dritte wird immer angeblendet, Tom Holland-Actor. Ah, der Schauspieler Tom Holland. Schaut, nee, habe ich noch nie gesehen. Denken wir so, Leute, kann man nicht mal gucken, wer das heute macht und dann kurz sagen, aber es ist immer so, dieses, ich finde, es ist auch so eine, jetzt gehen wir aber auch ganz gar anders hin, so eine urdeutsche Tugend, dieses muss man den kennen? Also dieses zu Schaustellen, dass einen das eigentlich überhaupt nicht interessiert. Habe ich das Gefühl, ist manchmal für Leute so ein, den soll ich kennen, muss man den kennen? Bei mir schwingt eine andere urdeutsche Tugend eher mit. Der Amerikaner, glaube ich, denkt ja, oh cool, ein Promi, wer ist das? Ah wow, cool, ich habe erstmal Bock drauf. Und ich glaube, der deutsche Ansatz ist eher so ein, hä, warum soll ich den kennen, warum soll ich mich jetzt freuen? Nur weil ich komme Holland hier. Ja, ich nehme es anders wahr, ich nehme es aber auch als Urdeutsch wahr, aber eher so aus einer Bodenständigkeit heraus. Also aus so einem Ausbildungsberuf, wir müssen erst mal die Grundlagen kennen, lernen, wir nehmen Formel 1 als handwerkliche Sportart wahr, wo es um Training geht, um Disziplin und es geht um die Hand-Augen-Koordination
und so Training
und das andere ist so
Beiwerk. Ja, ich kenne das nur
so von so verschiedenen Interviewformaten,
so eine YouTube-Reihe mit verschiedenen Interviews
und dann immer so die, es gibt
immer Kommentare von
muss man den kennen, muss man die kennen,
ist aber auch mit so einem, ich fühle mich gut, dass ich die Person nicht kenne, so ich bin da nicht so drin oder sowas. Ich kenne natürlich viele auch nicht, aber ich denke mir, okay, ich kenne natürlich nicht jeden, so ich bin natürlich nicht drin. Und dann das Unangenehmste, was war dann natürlich anscheinend gewinnt, dann diese Figur von Brad Pitt. Spoiler? Brat, das wollen wir den Film mal nicht mehr anschauen. Ja, ich glaube, den soll man sich sowieso nicht anschauen. Und dann filmen die tatsächlich auf dem Podest. Er steht da, links neben ihm steht Charles Leclerc, der wirklich Zweiter geworden ist an dem Tag. Und die müssten dann nochmal, sollten die dann jubeln. Und die sind gerade ein Rennen gefahren, dann schütteln sie den Champagner und so. Und wirklich, da habe ich dann wieder gedacht, holy shit, du musst nicht nur eine Figur spielen, die gerade einen Formel-1-Sieg errungen hat, sondern er muss auch noch gegen das echte Umfeld ankämpfen. Ja, ja. Also ich kenne mir ja auf der Bühne, also wenn man alles baut, ein Studio baut mit einem Podium und so, da hast du ein Schauspielerrechts neben dir, da könnte ich doch authentischer ein Sieg spielen, ein Formel-1-Sieg spielen, als neben den echten Formel-1-2. Ich würde mir vorstellen, wie die letzte Dulli ... Alles, was auch so auf so Gefallensbasis ist. Wir haben vor kurzem auch in einem echten Gericht gedreht, wo wir so einen Gerichtssaal hatten, aber in dem Rest des Gebäudes mit ganz vielen anderen Gerichtssälen waren ganz normale Verhandlungen von Leuten, wo wahrscheinlich viel auf dem Spiel steht, die halt da jetzt irgendwie über keine Sorgerecht oder was auch immer da irgendwie eine Fahndung haben und wir halt
als Comedy-Truppe, als
und wir albern da rum und mit
unserem Catering und es kam halt ein paar Mal jemand
von dem, von dem Gordermann und meinte so,
ihr müsst bitte wirklich leise sein so.
Und da geht es bei Leuten um das Leben.
Wir sind einfach die grössten Vollidioten.
Wir sind halt die Hampelmänner,
die halt dann da irgendwie ihren Quatsch
Quark machen. Dreh den Hampelmann-Gericht, baut euch in Hampelmann-Gericht.
Ja genau, baut ein Studio, aber es ist halt so, dürfen wir bei euch drehen, die so, ja wenn es sein muss halt, aber macht schnell bitte. Und dann nerven wir auch noch den ganzen Tag und die so, hey Leute, hier sind wirklich wichtige Verhandlungen, das ist wichtig für die Leute. und wieder
und du wahrscheinlich mit so einer Perücke
irgendwie und mit so einem
komischen Kostüm viel zu gross. Niemand checkt, was los ist. Die Tür geht auf. Könnt ihr bitte leise sein? Im Hintergrund weint irgendjemand auf der Anklagebank und du drehst dich so vom Buffet um, hast so ein Big Mac im Gesicht und hast so eine Richterperücke auf, die so wackelt beim Umdrehen. Ja, genau.
Und dann auch in dem Gerichtssaal, auch der Aufnahmeleiter, Leute, ich weiss, es ist
alles Spaß, aber bitte drückt
hier auf keine Knöpfe oder so, weil da kommt
halt dann wirklich Sicherheitspersonal,
wenn ihr auf irgendeinen dummen Knopf drückt.
Es ist einfach Kindergarten.
Es ist wirklich, Dreh ist einfach Kindergarten.
So tun als ob. Und diese Welten sollten nicht vermischt werden. Und das passiert bei diesem Formel-1-Film. Genau. Und selbst wenn der gut ist, wir waren alle, alle Formel-1-Fans, die das potenzielle Publikum dieses Films sein könnten, haben auch gesehen, wie er gemacht wurde. Und leider haben die den Fehler gemacht und sie haben vermengt. Sie haben die So-tun-als-ob-Welt vermengt mit der richtigen Welt. Und dagegen stinkt So-tun-als-ob immer ein bisschen ab. Das ist wirklich unangenehm. Das anzugucken war unangenehm. An Brad Pitt wird gerüttelt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, an Mythos und an Menschen. Ich finde auch so geil, dass dieser Film einfach einen einzigen Schauspieler hat, so als einfach sonst jemand, der auch noch die ganze Zeit einen Helm trägt. Da würde ich mir auch denken so, ich meine, jetzt für einen Film kann ich auch ohne Helm, also da würden die Fans durchdrehen, das geht natürlich nicht. Wahnsinn, also fand ich super interessant, dass du zu beobachten, diese Entzauberung des Films? Ich muss bei Formel 1 gerade wirklich
überlegen, was mir daran gefällt, weil ich finde die Rennen
extrem langweilig, aber ich mag
irgendwie alles drumrum irgendwie so. Ich mag
die Dokus und ich mag die
die, jedes einzelne Team macht dann auch so seine
Videos und so und ich mag die Leute und das Drama
so, aber die Rennen selber
interessiert mich einfach nicht.
Lehne dich rein, lehne dich rein die Langeweile.
Ich hätte das irgendwann zu schätzen gelernt,
die Langeweile von Dingen,
die immer wiederkommend sind, kann
sehr Interessiert mich einfach nicht. Lehne dich rein. Lehne dich rein die Langeweile. Ich hätte das irgendwann zu schätzen gelernt. Die Langeweile von Dingen, die immer wiederkommend sind, kann sehr gut sein. Also dieser Formel-1-Sonntag, wo man dann auch allen im Umfeld sagt, stör mich nicht, ihr wisst, ich gucke da immer meine Formel 1. Also ich glaube auch, mein Vater hat das auch immer geguckt. Und ich glaube, ein grosser Bestandteil an diesem Ich-guck-jetzt-Formel-1 war einfach so Ruhe.
Sich Ruhe, sich die Ruhe nehmen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen so tun als ob.
Also man geht so, man lehnt sich so rein.
Es geht nicht darum, dass man immer zu einem Rennen will oder so.
Nee, es geht darum, ihr wisst doch, ich mag das gern.
Eigentlich sind viele Hobbys nur eine Ausrede, um zu sagen, lasst mich mal bitte in Ruhe. Und deswegen glaube ich... Wandelnde Red Flag Leute, die sagen, ich mag alle Sportarten. Und dann sind sie auch wirklich immer vor dem Fernsehungsrat. Aber auch sowas wie Baseball oder so, die ewig lang dauern mit Innings und niemand checkt es, aber viele Leute sagen wahrscheinlich so, jetzt ist Baseball, jetzt lasst mich einfach fucking in Ruhe.
So der Mensch muss konstant ausreden, sich ausdenken, dass man einfach mal in Ruhe gelassen wird. So ein Schutzschild um sich rum, wo einfach mal alle Leute weggedrückt werden und so. Deswegen, das ist wichtig. Ja, ironischerweise ein Schutzschild vor den eigengemachten Konventionen. Ja. Also wenn Eheleute sich Hobbys besorgen, um nicht in der Ehe befindlich zu sein, laufen sie weg vor einem Problem, was sie gar nicht haben müssten. Sie müssen nicht in einer Ehe sein. Weisst du, was ich meine? Okay, das eröffnet natürlich interessante Perspektiven. Müsse nicht. Man kann es, wenn man es will. Man muss es nicht. Menschen laufen weg vor Regeln, von denen sie glauben, sie müssten die erfüllen, weil die Gesellschaft es macht. Man muss sich mal freimachen. Interessante, interessante, habe ich so noch nicht drüber nachgedacht. Ich soll mich selbst schütteln? Oder wie Brad Pitt jemanden haben, der mich schüttelt? Fühlt euch von mir geschüttelt und macht euch mal frei von euren gesellschaftlichen Ambitionen, vor denen ihr dann mit komplexen Konstrukten, wie zum Beispiel, ich mag mein Formel 1 am Sonntag, fliehen müsst, freimachen. Ihr könnt euch ja freimachen. Aha, okay. Ne, das saß, ich nehme das auf jeden Fall mit auf die Reise. Nehmen das mal mit auf die Reise, geht damit mal schwanger. Wir machen mal 70 Runden in Melbourne mit dieser Idee und dann schauen wir mal, wie es, finde ich, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. 57. Finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Ja, ich habe jetzt auch gedacht, der einzige Ort, an dem man sich noch langweilt, ist im Bett vorm Einschlafen. So, du liegst da rum und denkst dir, pfff, soll ich nochmal einen Laptop aufmachen? Und ich habe ja Army, so dass ich meinen Arm so aufstelle und den dann so wieder runter... Army? Army, so den Arm so aufstelle und dann den so runterklappen lasse. und das ist echte Langeweile, wenn du nicht einschlafen kannst. Das ist echt von Geburt an ist der Mensch mit dem Problem konfrontiert, dass du nicht sofort einschlafen kannst und einfach rumliegst. Das passt thematisch sehr gut, weil gerade haben wir so gesprochen über so tun als ob. Einschlafen ist so tun als ob man schläft. Ach, du schauspielerst Schlafen, um einzuschlafen? Ich meine, wir sind alle keine geborenen Schauspieler, du schon, du bist Schauspieler,
I guess, okay, hast du hier nochmal auf die Wiedergeschriebene wieder schon. Aber wir
alle spielen Schau beim Einschlafen. Wirklich, das ist eine Technik?
Sag mir mal eine andere Sache, wo du so tust, als ob, um es dann zu tun. Autofahren. Nein, nein, nein, du fährst Auto. Ne, ich mache Hub, Hub, ich tue so, als würde ich Autofahren und plötzlich bewegt sich das Ding, das Stahlkawenzmann. Okay, dann solltest du, okay, das ist sehr gefährlich. Plötzlich bewegt sich das Stahlkawenzmann und ich denke mir, okay, wie geht das jetzt? Das wäre mein Name für ein Auto. VW Kavenzmann.
VW Kavenzmann, ja.
Der Fiat Caracho.
Einfach mal voran. Ja, Fiat Zampano.
Fiat Zampano, ja. Wir brauchen generell mehr Autos.
Bessere Autonamen.
Mehr Doppeldecker auch, wirklich.
Man muss ewig Parkplatz suchen, überall so.
Was ist aus der Doppeldecker-Idee geworden?
Warum mieten wir uns nicht? Nee, ich stellst ein Auto. Das war meine Idee. Dass du über dem anderen Auto parken kannst? Die können wegfahren, aber der Radabstand ist ein bisschen grösser. Und dann kannst du hochfahren, mit so ganz langen Beinchen. Aber wie steigt man dann aus? Hast du so eine kleine Strickleiter, die da ... Nee, das ist wie beim Flugzeug, du drückst auf so einen Knochen und dann kommt so eine aufblasbare Rutsche runter. Und dann rutscht er direkt in den Verkehr rein. Das konnten wir nicht um, also diese ganze Idee, dass wir wieder umsetzen konnten, vielen Dank nochmal ans Team. Danke an Fiat. Vielen Dank an Laura Bradwand, vielen Dank an Philipp Pisanowitsch, Carl Gleisel, Richard Wagenhund, Mehmet Schmepp, Fennelander Carano. Leider konnten wir sich erinnern, das Ausklappen ist ultralaut. Ja. Das ist ein Sprengstoff, also das ist tatsächlich einmal TNT, was die ... In die Rutsche rein, damit es schnell ... In die Rutsche rein, damit es schnell ... Ja, extrem laut. Genau, deswegen darf man es bislang nicht in geschlossenen Ortschaften parken, du musst bislang runterspringen, weil es macht ... Ja. Es ist zu laut, und das einzuwickeln dauert auch ewig. Witziges Spiel für alle da draußen.
Hat auch was mit Autos zu tun. Witziges Spiel
vor allem für die Autobahnen.
Spiele ich immer gern. Na, auffahren und
Lichtruppe.
Genau, und wenn jemand hinter einem ist,
mal kurz bremsen einfach mal.
Das liebe ich.
Das checkt sich manchmal nicht.
Mal mega spart, aber auch vielleicht im Kreistest.
Und da gucke ich mir immer gerne die Kennzeichen an und ich stelle mir vor, es ist ein Name und dann lache ich, weil es witzig klingt. Letztens gesehen. Ich höre Podcasts. Oh, okay, du hast halt echt ein paar richtig geile Ideen dabei. Ne, was ich mache, ich gucke mir das Kennzeichen an und denke mir, das könnte ja ein Name sein. Letztens zum Beispiel gesehen Omp.
O-H-M-P.
Ostholstein.
Ostholstein, M-P.
Und Omp ist ein, finde ich,
grundsolider Name.
Wenn ihr meinen seid, das ist meine WG,
das ist Lisa,
Claudia, Manfred und Omp.
Und genau, also hier ist die Küche wichtig wert. Omp ist der Name?
Wie bitte? Omp ist der Name? Genau. Lisa Laura Martin Ohm. Hi Ohmp. Hi. Das ist sein Name? Also so heisst du es einfach, der Name steht. Ich heisse Ohmp. Kann ich mal deinen Ausweis sehen? Klar, ja Ohmp, Ohmp Wagner, wenn wir zu Hause heissen, hallo Ohmp. Was? Ohmp. Jetzt finde ich das viel spannender als der Fakt, dass du so heisst, finde ich, dass alle bei dir in der Familie so heissen. Naja, bei mir im Dorf heissen alle Omp. Also die meisten heissen Omp. O-H-M-P. O-H-M-P, genau, Omp. Ja, spannend, ja. Wer heisst du? Ähm, Kneftstoff. Kneftstoff. Ach so, na gut. Also die Küche ist da hinten. Kneftstoff, ja, der ist auch ein guter Name, aber macht das gerne mal, schaut auf Kennzeichen und falls ihr witzige Namen findet, schickt sie mir gerne. Ja, oder lest mal im Buch. Auf jeden Fall, vielen Dank für deinen Vorschlag. Nein, bitte beim Autofahren kein Buch lesen. Den Fehler habe ich zu oft, viel zu oft gemacht.
Ich war noch bei Stolz und Massenkarambolage. Das war eine ganz schlechte Idee. Ganz schlechte Idee. Das wäre mal ein Titel für ein Buch. Ja, Stolz und Massenkarambolage. Stolz und Massenkarambolage. Ja, liebe ich. Ja, finde ich gut. Nie gelesen.
Auch nie gelesen.
Letztens mir in die Hände gefallen, Madame Bovary. Auf Französisch klingt sau langweilig, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich bin auch, ich bin wirklich, ich werde immer glücklicher mit meiner fast schon zügellosen, anti-intellektuellen Einstellung. Mir ist alles scheißegal. Hegelkant können zur Hölle fahren. Die können mir alle mal den Poppes abwischen. Ist mir alles egal. Und Flaubert und so ist mir doch egal. Früher hätte ich so ein Buch in der Hand gehalten und mir gedacht, wow, okay, stimmt. Mal haben, Boveri, das muss man eigentlich mal lesen. Dann müsste man sich mal Zeit freischaufeln. Jetzt sehe ich mir, pfff, pfff, da bin ich mittlerweile. Du wirst zu deinen Schulbullies. Da bin ich mittlerweile angekommen, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich muss immer mehr eingestehen, ganz im Gegenteil, die Sachen, die so wahnsinnig zu Klethiker, die muss man gelesen haben und so. Und dann denkt man, Jesus Christ, wahrscheinlich hasse ich das. Und dann liest man das und denkt, ja, ist schon ganz cool. Und dann denkt man, ich bin gar nicht so besonders, ich bin gar nicht besonders. Ich mag genau die Sachen, die alle mögen, die Menschheit mag.
Ich bin am Ende einfach ein boring ass Mensch.
Ja, aber es gibt auch ein paar Klassiker, also gerade auch im Kinderbuchbereich.
Wo alle lieben.
Ich bin mittlerweile sehr kritisch.
Wo alle gelogen haben.
Wo alle gelogen haben, ja.
Genau.
Und es ist auch Bullshit.
Zum Beispiel Regenbogenfisch.
So, es gibt ja nur so drei, vier Kinderbücher, die auch super Klassiker sind. Es gibt Raub Nimmersatt, die Grosse Krabbe, der Regenbogenfisch und der Maulwurf Grabowski. Wer hat den Maulwurf auf den Kopf gekackt? Und was anderes, es gibt zwei Maulwürfe. Und dann gibt es noch den Maulwurf Grabowski. Warum ist der Maul Maulwurf so arg überrepräsentiert bei Kindern? Gute Frage. Hast du immer den Maulwurf gesehen? Tatsächlich noch nie. Hast du immer den Regenbogenfisch gesehen? So, Regenbogenfisch, kurze Zusammenfassung, Regenbogenfisch. In dem Buch Regenbogenfisch geht es ums Anderssein. Es ist ein Buch übers Anderssein. Der Regenbogenfisch ist anders als die anderen Fische. In welcher Hinsicht ist der anders? In drei. So, erstens, er ist bunt. Deswegen heisst er Regenbogenfisch. Gibt es keine anderen Regenbogenfische im Buch? Nein, es gibt einen einzigen Regenbogenfisch. Er ist bunt. Wie sehen die anderen aus? Einfach blau? Relativ eintönig, hellblau, dunkelblau oder so, aber soft ist er eintöniger. Also erstens, Er ist bunt. Wie sehen die anderen aus? Einfach blau? Relt eintönig, hellblau, dunkelblau oder so, aber soft-harmisch. Ist er eintöniger, genau. Also erstens, er ist bunt. Zweitens, er hat Glitzerschuppen. Drittens, er hat Glitzerflossen. Das sind die drei Dinge, in denen er sich von den anderen unterscheidet. Der Pedant, der ich bin, kurz mal. Genau, das ist ja nötig, das ist nötig. Er ist einfach schöner. Er ist schöner. Und darum geht es auch. Aber deswegen meine ich, er ist ja nicht in drei. Ja, es wird noch wichtig. So, und das ist nämlich auch das Buch beginnt mit, der Regenbogenfisch ist glücklich, weil er ist der schönste, er hat die Glitzerschuppen, die sonst niemand hat und er schwimmt glücklich durchs Meer. Und dann kommt ein anderer Fisch und sagt, willst du mir nicht eine Schuppe geben? Der Regenbogenfisch sagt pfff. So wie du so stolz das Wort hast. Und dann kommt, und das finde ich auch von dem Storytelling her eine Schwäche, kommt mehr oder weniger schlagartig der Punkt, wo der Regenbogenfisch unglücklich ist und sagt, warum spielt denn niemand mit mir? Er gibt, aber Moment, er gibt Leuten das nicht bewusst. Nee, nee, nee. Das ist das Ding. Normalerweise, die Netflix-Note wäre jetzt schon gewesen, der Charakter ist unsympathisch. Die Hauptfigur ist unsympathisch. Netflix würde den Regenbogenfisch heute gar nicht mehr produzieren. Und der Regenbogenfisch irgendwie ist unglücklich und kommt damit nicht mehr klar, ohne dass es einen Grund gibt. Ich finde, wenn eine Figur ihr Leben lang auf Weise A gelebt hat und plötzlich nicht mehr, muss es dafür irgendeinen Grund geben. Gibt es hier gar nicht. Er sagt einfach nur, hä, warum will niemand mit mir spielen? Die schleichende Erkenntnis. So, und dann geht er zum grossen, zum Tintenfisch und fragt um Rat und dann sagt er, gib mal bitte deine Glitzerschuppen her. Und der Regenbogenfisch sagt Pfff. So, und dann kommt der kleine Fisch nochmal an und sagt, willst du mir nicht deine Schuppen geben? Und dann sagt der Regenbogenfisch, ja, okay, eine kann ich dir geben, wird nicht schaden. Dazwischen hat sich nichts verändert? Nichts verändert. Außer sein Unglück. Jetzt gibt der Regenbogenfisch seine Glitzerschuppen ab, also Körperteile von sich gibt er ab, und gibt jedem anderen Fisch eine Glitzerschuppe, sodass am Ende alle... Ungefragt! Ne, die wollen das schon, die sagen, ah, so. Und dann haben alle Fische eine Glitzerschuppe, alle sind gleich und jetzt spielen sie auch mit dem Regenbogenfisch. So, ein paar Fragen. Erstens, was zur Hölle soll die Moral sein? Bezahl Leute, damit sie mit dir spielen wollen? Du kannst nur dann Freunde sein mit jemandem, wenn alle gleich sind, wenn alle eine Glitzerschuppe haben?
Klar, man kann sagen, sei nicht eitel und gib was von deinem Reichtum ab, aber das ist ja sein Körper so. Es ist ja nicht so, dass er jetzt viele Muscheln hat, sondern es ist sein Körper, seine Glitzerschuppen. Und ein paar andere Fragen noch. Er ist immer noch der einzige Fisch, der bunt ist, und er hat auch Glitzerflossen, die er nicht abgeben kann. Das heißt, er wird immer anders sein als die anderen Fische. Der zweite Teil ist ein bisschen Gore. Es ist Bullshit. Da muss er die, der reisst, da wird ihm dann die Flosse abgerissen. Da kommt dann eine Gang, eine Gangschlussfische. Ja, ja, ja, und dann kann er auch nicht mehr schwimmen und schwimmt nur im Kreis. Bis er sich dann zu Tode hungert. Das ist Bullshit, und da sage ich Klassiker hinterfragen. Klassiker radikal hinterfragen, was soll hier die Botschaft sein? Ja genau, es ist auch nicht ganz klar, also bei Währung, genau, ist das eine, ist ja auch nicht ganz klar, Schuppen hat man ja wahrscheinlich auch aus Gründen. Ja, richtig. Also er gibt ja etwas ab. Und er ist ja natürlich so geboren, es ist ja nicht so, als hätte die jetzt jemanden geklaut oder irgendwie vererbt oder so. Wachsen die nach? Nein, wachsen die nach? Ist das so eine Umverteilungskritik? Also Milliardäre werden aus dem eigenen Reichtum immer reicher, seine grossen Schuppen, der reiche Fisch, die wachsen ihm selber nach. Man weiss nicht, wofür die Schuppen stehen. Man weiss auch nicht, ob er die gebrauchen kann oder nicht, oder? Es ist nicht so, dass er die alle abgibt und dann kommt ein Schwertfisch ihm in die Seite rein und nur weil er die alle abgibt, hat es stirbt. Es ist einfach nur ein Zeichen für Schönheit. Und selbst wenn es eine Metapher für Schönheit ist, was ist die Botschaft? Gib deine Schönheit ab an die Hässlichen, damit ihr alle gleich seid. Also ich raff's wirklich nicht. Und warum heisst das Buch Regenbogenfisch, wenn die Tatsache, dass er bunt ist, keine Rolle spielt? Es geht nur um die Glitzerschuppen, nicht darum, dass er auch noch bunt ist, was nie zur Sprache kommt, niemanden interessiert und einfach nur random da ist. Und warum gibt man ihm Glitzerflossen? Das sagt, du bist für immer anders als alle anderen. Selbst wenn du deine Schuppen abgibst, du wirst immer auch die Glitzerflossen haben. Wir alle wissen warum, weil kleine Kinder es cool finden, wenn das Buch glitzert. Das ist der wahre Grund. Merch verkauft. Merch und einfach billiges Schauspiel, billiger Schauwert, Glitzerschauwert, aber die Botschaft bleibt komplett auf der Strecke. Gibt's nicht das hässliche Endline? Ja. Das ist ja ein ähnliches Prinzip, ne? Du hast das eine, aber da ist es halt ein bisschen cleverer vielleicht. Ja, da ist es eigentlich traurig, dass du hässlich bist, weil eines Tages bist du schön und dann bist du auch glücklich. Aber hässlich kann man weiterhin nicht. Okay, und Raupen immer satt. Raupen immer satt, isst, isst, isst und man bitte die Schmetterlinge. Genau, Raupen immer satt, die Butter, Raupen immer satt, wacht auf, frisst, frisst, frisst, frisst, frisst, hat dann Bauchweh, dann frisst es ein bisschen gesünder und dann wird es ein Kokon und ein Schmetterling. Warum geht es immer um Schönheit? Warum geht es immer darum, dass man keine Angst, keine Angst, am Ende bist du immer noch schöner. Also ich raff es nicht. Und deswegen hinterfragen und wirklich mal radikal, was da los ist. Immer hinterfragen. Was genau willst du da? Der Zerfall der Familie. Was für ein Zerfall? Der kontinuierliche Zerfall dieser Familie.
Wo man auch sagen kann, ist das nicht alles ein bisschen gewollt? Also da gibt es Thomas Buddenbrock, der... Ja gut, aber es zeigt jetzt ein Rechen der bürgerlichen Vorstellung und Werte der Gesellschaft. Ja, aber dann nur, weil er dann Zahnprobleme hat und sich dann vielleicht nicht mehr so sehr um seine Gesundheit... Zahnstück für Faschismus. Ja, aber dass er dann sagt, gut, diese Firma, die führe ich nicht mehr so, wie mein Vater das geführt hat, sondern ich breche mit den Konventionen und mache es, wie ich selber führe. Das ist der Spieler von Vietnamkipp. Das geht halt gar nicht klar. Und er hat ja auch bunte Flossen. Ja, bitte Leute, tut uns den Gefallen und hinterfragt auch diese Folge. Ja, ich sag's, hinterfragt auch diese Folge. Radikale Exegese. Exegese. War ein Wort gesagt. Haut rein, wir wünschen euch ganz vielass und wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich nächste Woche beim Lesen, beim Lernen und beim Lachen.
Beim Autofahren und beim Lesen und am besten beides zusammen.
Ganz viel Spass, vielen lieben Dank, bis jetzt auch noch. Tschüss.